one Smallville ended in 2011 it felt
like we were all ready to move on to
bigger things
Superman and all his friends had once
again become big screen heroes and the
CW was gearing up for a new age of
superhero shows like arrow the flash and
legends of tomorrow even the cast of
Smallville seemed poised for bulletproof
careers outside the borders of their
little town in Kansas
now that the hit shows then off the air
for more than half a decade yes really
let's take a look at where some of the
biggest stars of Smallville are now Tom
Welling for a few years it seemed like
Smallville was going to be the start of
a long acting career for its lead Tom
Welling playing Smallville Clark Kent
was Wellings first major role but he
soon secured parts in the Steve Martin
comedy Cheaper by the Dozen and the 2005
horror remake the Fox and then cricket
for the next six years Tom Welling only
appeared in Smallville and since the
show went off the air he's only appeared
in three films Heartland in 2013 draft
day in 2014 and the choice in 2016
all of which received mixed reviews and
did nothing to reboot Wellings declining
status as an actor here's hoping Welling
career gets a second wind so he can take
flight once again
Alison Mack long before playing
journalist Chloe Sullivan and Smallville
Alison Mac was a common fixture on TV
she's had steady work on both television
shows and TV movies since 1989 and after
the end of Smallville max took a
recurring role in the FX shell Wilfred
and American Odyssey so she's certainly
been dizzy but even so the actress has
also found time for off screen projects
like her singing career Kristin Kreuk
after years of playing Lana Lang on
Smallville Kristin Kreuk decided to take
leave of the show in 2009 because she
felt there was more she could be doing
the actress was 19 when she first
appeared in the role and when she left
the show seven years later it was still
pretty much for only major parts
unfortunately the decision might not
have been as wise as she hoped because
she went on to star in the box-office
bomb streetfighters the Legend of
chun-li from there she served through a
handful of low key roles before finally
returning to CW with a recurring art in
Beauty and
these Michael Rosenbaum there's no doubt
that Michael Rosenbaum gave the
character of Lex Luthor just the right
amount of charm and likeability to
contrast the darkness within this is
Smallville meteor freaks alien ships
cryptic symbols these threats are real
perhaps the reason he was such a good
match for the DC Universe is that he'd
been a part of it before and stuck
around afterwards too he'd also done
voice work for the animated series
Batman Beyond and during Smallville's
run he went on to voice the flash in the
animated Justice League series overall
Rosen bounds career has been marked more
by voice acting than physical acting so
while you might not see him as much
anymore
keep those ears peeled because he still
as busy as ever John Glover Lionel
Luthor Alexis dad was the main daddy in
the earlier seasons of Smallville a role
perfectly fitting for John Glover
although he's often tried to avoid being
typecast as a villain he just seems to
keep getting soft in those roles after
all he was the slimy advertising guy in
Robocop Zoo the evil Jason would ruin
Batman and Robin and even the devil
himself in 1998 brimstone on top of that
he's voiced the Riddler in a long run of
animated DC shows hey when you've got it
you've got it Erica Durance Smallville
took its sweet time to bring Lois Lane
into the fold but in season four actress
Erica Durance finally introduced the
street smart reporter to the show like
her on-screen persona dorrance fit the
bill of being smart capable and slightly
neurotic outside of Smallville though
the Canadian actress hasn't had the best
of luck she's mostly appeared in a
string of B movies like the video game
flop House of the Dead and the
completely ignored butterfly effect -
along with a smattering of small roles
and various TV shows including a long
lasting turn in the CTV medical drama
saving hope so she's still showing the
same sort of gumption that made her
write for Lois
Annette O'Toole Smallville marks the
second time that Annette O'Toole fell
into the world of Clark Kent
the first being her stint as Lana Lang
in 1983 Superman 3 which means that in
the course of her career she's played
both Clark Kent's girlfriends
and his mom suppose I have to say said
I'm not going to find what I want
Smallville anymore Hugh at Smallville
after the sixth season but returned in
2010 for two more cameo episodes before
returning to small voles and other shows
TV movies and stage plays John Schneider
the actor portraying Jonathan Kent
Clark's dad was a busy working actor
long before he ventured into Smallville
he most famously played Bo Duke one half
of the duo on the original use of
Hazzard and had a long-running role on
dr. Quinn Medicine Woman
his folks Smallville career has been
just as prolific Justin Hartley before
Oliver green arrow queen got his own
show the hooded hero regularly appeared
on Smallville in this version Queen was
portrayed by Justin Hartley who liked
much of the younger cast of the show
counted this as his first big role prior
to getting cast as Oliver Queen though
Justin Hartley was actually slated to
star in an Aquaman series on the CW and
even filmed the pilot before the show
was dropped judging by the trailer it's
probably a good thing the network
decided to pass on Aquaman because
sometimes the world just isn't ready for
a bleached blond surfer who fights crime
Hartley has since returned to the TV
spotlight as Kevin on NBC's hit drama D
this is us Cassidy Freeman as Tess
Mercer and Smallville Cassidy Freeman
got to venture into some very weird
territory as the CEO of luthorcorp's
who's actually Lex's sister it was an
unforgettable twist to be sure and that
tends to be the case whenever Freeman
takes on even a small role like her
turns as jack in Once Upon a Time and a
400 year old bloodsucker in the Vampire
Diaries in Smallville rapped Freeman
found new work on Longmire Aaron Ashmore
this former child star and identical
twin to Sean of x-men Fame became a
series regular as Jimmy Olsen
The Daily Planet photographer who was
engaged to Khloe never a household name
Aaron Ashmore nevertheless mustered
enough star power to take the lead role
in a handful of low-budget horror movies
like 2009 Sphere Island and 2010's the
shrine before joining the main cast for
Syfy's well-received shell killjoys he
might still be a little jealous of his
look-alike siblings
because at least he got to play with
some sci-fi powers but what are you
gonna do thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to